man they're not let me get away with
anything
I later gentlemen welcome to the shield
part of the Marvel television channel hi
we're gonna have a little bit of fun
today because it's not often that you
get to introduce a new character and
that character sticks it is even more
unique when you introduce four new
characters to an already established
show and the audience embraces them in a
way that is so exciting for those of us
didn't make the show and write the show
that it's just been awesome and I want
to introduce you to some of the new
people who joined us and I'm going to
start with the first inhuman that we got
to get to know I his name is Luke and he
plays Lincoln
hey guys
the second new member of our cast I was
just I can't tell you how big a surprise
when we'll talk more about what that
means I just I can't tell you enough
good things about Henry who plays Mack I
never get tired of this joke so I do it
every time I can with him his real name
is Nick blood and he plays Lance hunter
his name should be Lance hunter and he
should play Nick blood nonetheless Nick
let's come on out
on our next new cast member almost needs
no introduction to you guys we know her
from some things like Friday Night
Lights and on WIC I she's a pal and when
we got a chance to be able to bring her
on
I could play Bobby Moore's eye there's
really not more I need to stay other
than Adrienne once you get out here
so there's a new kids if we're gonna
have new kids that must mean we must
have old kids for some of these guys
this is for you guys this is which is uh
what happens when Adrienne walks out
who's first comic-con is this all free
Oh
so I need you I need you to really make
them feel welcome can you get my fix
here
he struggled a lot at the beginning of
season at the end of the season he was
kicking ass on his own one of our
favorite favorite guys Ian come out here
he placed it
they started out as Fitzsimmons I think
we can safely say that there now Fitz
and Simmons and that would be because
well we hope that she's coming back and
that is Elizabeth why don't you come on
out here
hopefully we're going to get a chance to
talk a little bit about the fact that
this season weekend we got you got to
understand that Melinda made a very
complicated character we learned a lot
about her backstory but if you knew Ming
you wouldn't quite understand how those
two people could coexist but this year
we got to see a little bit of Ming
because she got to play a couple of
different roles anyway we'll talk about
that me much but out here
ah I almost don't have to say his name I
really I'm at a point now instead if I
just did this I stand with warden
this show started around an idea which
was that a young inexperienced but very
qualified hacker was trying to get into
she didn't know about her past she had a
name that she had chosen for herself hi
she many of you have pointed out didn't
have a last name because when we the
computer would say agent Skye but this
year was a real game-changer in a lot of
ways not only for the show but in
particular for someone who got a chance
to introduce a very important character
to the Marvel Universe and we no longer
referred to her as Skye referred to her
as Daisy Johnson chloë come on
we are all everyone here and everyone in
the production
I just thanks our lucky stars because we
get to work with Clark
you know I want to spend just a second
just talking to the the I just love
calling you guys the newbies it's the
best I so Luke and when this all started
and you got to come on board what was
that like I mean I you know this ship's
up and flying you can yeah on board
it's bloody scary I tell you these guys
are just these guys are just so good at
what they do and so coming on I just
wanted to kind of slip in unnoticed and
just true you know I just wanted to work
as hard as I could and it was pretty
cool getting to work with Chloe cuz she
knows how it's done
but look everyone made me feel really
welcome from the start and it's a really
cool family okay so here's the part that
I know all of you are sitting there home
going wait I he doesn't have an American
accent I don't understand what's what is
he putting on I think so now Luke you
got to do it for us
talking your American voice what do you
want me to say Jeff just cracks me up
now Henry you Henry you started out you
were kind of a quiet guy and then you
kind of became the action guy and then
towards the end of the season you kind
of became the funny guy like you just
had some good logic just who Harry who
are you on the show
I'm the guy who kills Gordon
so so Henry I again just you came on
you were like Mack the mechanic like and
all of a sudden you were out kicking ass
and running around what was that like a
lot of fun we do more of it and you're a
small guy you just stand up for for the
folks to be able to see I just say come
on on stood up at an island
we're not gonna make Nick stand out we
are gonna make Nick talk though so I
Nick you you came to the cast kind of at
the last second like I like that day
before we were shooting you flew in from
England yeah what was that experience
like oh yeah it's kind of nuts you guys
were all here weren't you doing
comic-con and I was shooting something
in London and wrapped that at like eight
o'clock that night got on a plane the
next morning after furiously landed in
LA having just spent the whole flight
just wired and you know not being able
to relax to sleep and then got picked up
driven set and we're straight into
costume and makeup and I snow before
then I said sir I said to one of the
ladies I was like oh can I keep some
where I can get a shower and freshen up
and stuff and they were like we kind of
need to get you into costume and makeup
stopping loose your makeup and then I
was upside down in a SUV with um Zeenat
of warrior princess yeah it was a yes is
where I but fun so so Adrian could you
understand anything you just said
I'm not having that problem every day
all right
so Bobby Moore's like you're a geek
what's that light it's pretty awesome to
play this character as a huge hell of a
fan
and there's a lot of pressure coming in
on it
you know I don't want to disappoint
anybody but everybody's been really
awesome and you guys have been very warm
and inviting and these guys especially
you know you guys are like family so not
you but everybody else you know this
group seems very clear because they're
serious they're serious actors they're
doing serious things they're they have
serious missions they are constantly out
saving the world from serious bad guys I
have some serious footage I need to show
you it's very serious so I think right
now what I would love to do is open the
floor to some Q&A and then that way we
can talk to the rest of our cast here do
we have people lined up there Hey look
at that
hi how you doing hi rooms Erica um hi
Erica um I just wondering you guys I
know you guys have a lot of fun on set
and I was what gave you that who told
you that
um I was wondering what the first
impression that you had what was the
first impression you had of the person
sitting right next to on the right
you start with you card who hurt I don't
remember when we first met oh yeah I do
it was at the table read I think this is
more I wonder sorry I never tell your
first impression of me I can't I can't
be s um I loved Chloe Bennett's from the
first moment I met her she was psyched
to be here she was incredibly
enthusiastic and game and brave and
really brought everything we needed to
make the thing work and it's just been
like that for all these people really I
mean we got to meet we got to meet the
new people who showed up and gave us
this incredible infusion of new energy
last season
and the people like Brett I love him I
love him and Elizabeth and everybody
we're just so lucky to have this cast
because I feel like what really is
working is the way that people show up
ready to play and really have fun
together and I think that's all I got to
say so yeah I just it just be too much
fun I'm just going to pick out people
that and do it so Ian and Elizabeth when
you when you first met what was that
like because you actually had to do
something different I might helping you
with this yeah your screen test talk
about yourself in town last round of
audition was together and we had the
scenes that were based on Episode six of
season one I think when I was l know you
guys were at the bottom of the ocean and
you were OH
had to figure out how to get out of so
we were it was the first thing they read
I was there they were not yeah that was
that I am was see oh yeah probably that
we were emotional wrecks because the
scenes were very intense and that was
all we had that time together so yeah
and we were the only two people that
could understand each other
oh and and now yeah I love that Megan
smiling because she knows where this is
going so for the first season you went
and Ward Brad were special friend
you were you were special friends you
were friends with benefits we had you
were you were bring I think is what
people call it we were what yeah I guess
oh oh yeah there you go oh I give you
something more met yeah it was out of
necessity
I mean he was there and we were stuck on
a bus for months on end and he was
flexing his muscles all the time so I
had to help him you know
flex we also had a co-pilot in this by
the name of Jack Daniels he seemed to
help things a little bit as well
though yeah but boy it was a mistake huh
and it's it's actually one of my
favorite stories and I think we may have
told it before but I can't not tell it
and that is there was a day when we all
were out at the racetrack and we brought
you the real end of what was episode 16
which was after Captain America Winter
Soldier and we discovered that there the
h-word was now something that we could
say the H word is Hydra and we brought
the cast together and we gave them the
last few pages and in the last few pages
war did some really terrible things
can we eat checked those people can
Eisley security no that's great can I
see how is that signed how is hail Hydra
signed you plants is that there's a we
have a signer in front and hail Hydra
oh shoot look at that that might be our
new salute because this is a little fist
X long iron comments what so so you guys
were given the things and then some of
you had some really interested in what
was your first reaction when you found
out that that war was Hydra oh it's
really difficult for him to talk why
can't talk about right now
and and and Chloe I you have you said
something about um yeah what did you say
well we were in Elizabeth's trailer
because it's the cleanest and they sat
us down they gave us these red pages and
they're like we wanted to want to read
this together and I was like oh we're
all fired
and then so we were reading it and then
it turns out the big reveal of you
shooting hand in the face and I was I
immediately go huh I kissed him and
amigos huh
and yeah me
haha
hey hey my daughter and the clean
version is I said what I slept with hell
that's not what she thanks for clearing
that up
yeah it was a bit of a surprise to the
gang let's take another question from
the audience
hi my name is Tim my question is what
lessons have you guys learned while
working on agents of shield hmm what if
you guys learned while working on use of
shields I Luke what have you learned
while you've been on a field
Chloe is crazy oh yeah that's right
that's the lesson okay me I'm crazy and
Clark what have you learned while you've
been on on shield very much the same
thing that's the main lesson ever you
guys are talking to my boyfriend
Elizabeth's trailers clean and Chloe's
crazy I mean is ridiculously cute uh
Nick what have you learned that you've
been on shield um to to stand on my toes
when I'm doing seems Aviva at ease to
Elizabeth and I've learned to pronounce
really long words that sound sciency but
you're you actually you're a doctor in
real life you you actually know all
those words no yeah I do yet that is
true it comes at birth with being
British which is it
uh next question hi my name is Amelia
and um I was wondering if you have space
for an eight year old
I think we do now well sis since Jed and
Jeff and Marissa aren't here I get to go
shore after work probably could make all
of season three about that Amelia let me
just say that one of the things we're
most proud of it's shield is the fact
that anyone can run shield and that we
have a number of very strong women who
might be running shield at some point we
have the amazing precedent that were
honored to share a timeslot with and
Peggy Carter another strong powerful
woman who's more than capable of running
shield and just from the few moments
we've spent with you today I feel that
someday you could run she
as long as you stay away from Ward hey
there's space on my team - whichever
okay all right Amelia I just I as a
question like if if Ward we're putting
together a team is that something
anybody here would be interested in
joining okay a lot of Dark Souls in here
today little a little bit of a division
we'll see what happens along the way do
we have another question little closer
to the line I think I'm closer to the
micro turn the mic on yeah it's on yeah
there we go okay um nerves my name is
Jennifer and I'm a military navy doctor
and my questions for Ian this is going
to go well I've had to take care a lot
of brain trauma and I'm really impressed
how you've handled um your your injury
and I was wondering how you prepared for
it oh thanks that's really cool to know
um to be honest a lot of the work was
done for me really and by Jeff and and
and Jed and MO and all the rest of
writers they committed a lot of research
for me and I just cannot follow it
through really so a lot of its really
done to them I think you did a lot of
research yourself I did so yeah yeah I
did as well kind of yeah and we kind of
did that but they did they did the music
he's being modest you yeah he worked
very hard I think for me for me one of
the most surprising things to happen to
fits this season is you know he had
something like what you know what
happened was a very very serious thing
and we were just very mindful that being
very respectful to it at all times
because it's a real thing like you know
that you've experienced it affects a lot
of people
but then also for me exposing it not you
know within that not one of my teammates
thought you know walk on a wheelchair
fess up will get my monkey I have to
honestly say that's the longest that Ian
has ever spoken on a panel oh yeah I you
guys got to get a load who's coming up
now come on
hi everybody we have a very serious
question
I'm agent May 9h at sky you're now agent
Daisy Johnson at it guys look at me okay
our question is beside your own
characters on agents of shield who are
your favorite Marvel characters and why
one who's that for Daniel Rand iron fist
crow Peggy Carter Oh Fitz Mockingbird
well I can give a producer you the board
to sit at sevens amyloid thank you gotta
go with Mac yeah no Bobby I'm
mockingbird
I gotta say the Hulk uh I think I think
we have time for one more question
I love your outfit so much I was
wondering if we could see something from
season three the problem with that is
that we have we have not started
shooting but but you know what if there
was a way that I don't know if you've
seen but we've been like running around
with GoPros and having a lot of fun and
wow I hope this isn't recording whatever
that's doing there and if we had a
chance if we could if we could just
sneak into the writers room there's a
good now if you see what said more up to
like find out what's coming we could
find out what's coming like with a GoPro
I wonder whether or not there's anyone
here from the Marvel IT security team
who could tap into what's going on right
now in our secret headquarters
Oh Jill will be returning on September
29th a comic-con exclusive that we're
going to let you know because we always
like letting you know stuff if you're
fans of the Inhumans joining us will be
we're sorry
what quick question
said something about Simmons on there
it's actually let me just do this we'll
get to that a second there's there we're
going to get there it said she's very
dead but the character of lash that you
guys know that was drawn by Jo mad he's
big he's huge and he's coming to the
show now I'm sorry is there a problem
over here but also me I'm what is the so
there was that I don't know a few words
next to my name on that ball what did it
say I didn't see it I can't see that far
I'm old
it said I'm dead I said already very
dead already very dead yeah I don't know
wow we've run out of time thank you very
much
you